veuille ou non déjà sans gratter
l'eurovision est de retour pour sa 66e
édition dans cette compétition les
costumes et le charisme compte autant
que la musique les artistes prennent
lors d'essayages au sérieux
la ville de turin est l'hôte du concours
cette année après la victoire du groupe
madness qui en 2021
l'italie espère décrocher une nouvelle
récompense avec la ballade romantique du
duo mahmoud et blanco
l'ukraine figurent aussi parmi les
favoris
[Musique]
elle est représentée par un groupe de
rap folk appelé kallouch orchestra
alors que la guerre fait rage chez eux
les musiciens ont reçu une autorisation
spéciale pour voyager et représenter
leur pays pour les fans de l'eurovision
la participation de l'ukraine est
hautement symbolique
c'est une distraction et peut-être que
ça nous donnera un peu plus de courage
pour dire que malgré la guerre nous
essayons d'être optimiste
il faut envoyer un message de solidarité
à l'ukraine l'europe est avec l'ukraine
et l'ukraine fait partie intégrante de
notre au total 40 états sont représentés
la russie elle a été exclue du concours
un jour après l'invasion de le crâne